مصرفها فدرل والبركه باتا تحت يد البنك
المركزي بعد تعثرهما على وقع انهيار
اقتصاديا ضرب القطاع برمته
خطوه المركزيه هذه الطبقه اقرار قانوني
اعاده هيكله المصارف واعتبرها خبراء مدخلا
لتصفيه البنوك المتعثره
المنتخب
المصري في لبنان تتطلب مش متوفره لدى مصرف
لبنان اولاد الدوله اللبنانيه
السلطات اللبنانيه للمباشره باعاده هيكله
المصارف على نحو منصف والاعتراف بالخسائر
الماليه الكبيره وتوزيعها على نحو يضمن
حقوق المبدعين ونبه البنك الى مؤشرات
الاقتصاديه تثير القلق لاسيما الارتفاع
القياسي لمعدل التضخم خلال العام الجاري
وهو من اعلى المعدلات عالميا وفي المقابل
رطبات ان في اقرار الاصلاحات الوضع خطه
لاعاده هيكله
السياسيه لوضع صندوق في الدولي لا يمضي
الاتفاق النهائي مع لبنان واليوم البنك
الدولي عم بيضوي كمان على اهميه هذا
الموضوع التاخير باعاده هيكله المصارف راح
تؤدي الى مزيد من انهيار سعر صرف الليره
اصلاح القطاع المصرفي يبدو معطلا اذ يقبع
مشروع قانوني اعاده هيكله المصارف في
ادراج البرلمان منذ اشهر الى جانب مشاريع
ماليه اصلاحيه اخرى وهناك تتجاذبه المصالح
السياسيه والخلافات العميقه التي تعطل خطه
الانقاذ الاعاقه السياسيه
وبالتالي المذيعين اذن يتواجهوا بحقيقه
انه الدوله تريد شطب 60 مليون زيهم هذه هي
المشكله الحقيقيه لانه هذا الوضع ولا
الحكومه قادر تواجه هذا الوضع يصف الخبراء
عدد المصارف التجاريه في لبنان بالفائده
عن حاجه الاقتصاد وذلك رغم اللجوء الى
اغلاق عشرات الفروع منذ اندلاع الازمه في
عام 2019 وتسريح اكثر من 5000 موظف
تعول السلطات اللبنانيه على استعاده توازن
المصارف من خلال اعاده الهيكله المرتقبه
للقطاع المنهار الا ان التحدي الاصعب امام
المصارف هو كسب ثقه المذيعين الذين خسروا
اموالهم ثقه يصعب ترميمها عبر خطط ماليه
وقد لا تعود قبل سنوات طوال كاترين حنا
الجزيره بيروت